and finally new rule and this one goes
out to our own show business industry
here in Hollywood you can go ahead and
make every TV show and movie about the
exact same thing but if you do you can't
call the newspaper that covers that
industry variety now I know
conservatives think Hollywood ruined
America by promoting race mixing drugs
and twisted smut and I agree those
things should be taught at home but
that's not how Hollywood ruined America
it did it by making everything about
superheroes if they remade singing in
the rain today it would be called dance
man versus wet insurrection if all I
ever wanted to do was watch people fight
and fly and fly and fight I travel on
United
easy
listen to this lineup of TV shows
currently on the air daredevil flash
Gotham Supergirl
agents of shield legends of tomorrow
Luke Cage Jessica Jones arrow preacher
iron fists which I hope is not porn and
in the fall we're getting more the
defenders the gifted The Punisher
Krypton Inhumans and that's just TV at
the multiplex last year we had Captain
America 3 x-men 6 Batman vs Superman
Deadpool
Doctor Strange Suicide Squad and Ninja
Turtles 5 and already this year we've
had Wolverine 3 and Lego Batman with
Wonder Woman Justice League spider-man 6
and 4 3 in the can and if you have that
many guys in your can you'd be far too
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and if you're asking what's the problem
the problem is that superhero movies
imprint this mindset that we are not
masters of our own destiny and the best
we can do is sit back and wait for
star-lord and a [ __ ] raccoon to sweep
in and save our sorry asses forget hard
work government institutions diplomacy
investment we just need a hero to rise
and so we put out the bat-signal for one
man who could step in and solve all of
our problems very quickly and that's how
we got our latest superhero Orange
sphincter
[Applause]
yes orange figures sent from Planet
[ __ ] to save save mankind protected
by his power smirk and his golden helmet
joined by faithful allies Boy Wonder and
gingi mutant turtle and his Alfred
captain buzzkill our inspector never
stops battling his arch-nemesis crooked
Hillary and her vile sidekick private
server
like Batman Orange sphincter is a
billionaire socialite from Gotham like
Superman he has a red cape but where is
it in the front like Aquaman he can
communicate with whales and like
spider-man he has a spidey sense that
allows him to see things other people
cannot the field was it looked like a
million million and a half people which
all would be funnier if so many people
in this country didn't really believe in
Orange sphincter didn't really believe
that he possesses super deal-making
powers and a superior brain that can
solve in minutes issues that have
plagued the country for decades after
all he has actually said in a short
parity of time I understood everything
there was to know about healthcare and
it would take an hour and a half to
learn everything there is to learn about
missiles even Brainiac couldn't do that
peace between Israel and the
Palestinians it's something that I think
is frankly maybe not as difficult as
people have thought over the years yes
because they were mere mortals
whereas Orange sphincter
like all superheroes doesn't feel a need
to play by the rules
on tax returns fraternizing with the
enemy
grabbing [ __ ] respecting facts
conflicts of interest these are all the
concerns of smaller men as he put it
during an address to the people of Earth
I alone can fix it so how does this
superhero story and what is the fate of
Orange sphincter well this one is a
little bit trickier because in this one
the superhero is the villain and that
should make us all remember that it miss
fight for America we need to be our own
superheroes
[Applause]